something creepy is going on  y'all see it whoa toast the ghost writer  it's not easy being the new kid the menu  board says come together missus your  book they ever seen this bizarre  messages  this never happened denials I'm pretty  sure it's never happened at any school  Alice's Adventures in Wonderland  who's ready to let the characters out of  the book Mad Hatter  Alex erratic that's mr. W rabbit to you  [Music]  why did it go slower release these kids  find the book and read it it's only  where we're gonna solve this mystery do  you have anything to eat  nope so now we can hear animals talking  where is my dinner  I have gone tired of Zee cheap kibble  goes only hang around then they have  some sort of unfinished business  something bigger a real secret  [Music]  you are quite a small cat what I like  inside my makeup orange ah  [Music]  hey hey the whole city can supercool you  have no idea  you